And the British government said
"Slow your roll there, Louis [Leakey].
We are not sending a young 26 year old blonde woman
to Tanzania to study apes without an escort."
And by escort, they of course meant a man.
They didn't want her to go without a man to protect her.
She said, "Okay, great. I'll take an escort."
She took her mother, Van.
So this is Van Goodall. On the left on the beach
at Gombe, and then in her tent.
So Van and Jane set up the study of chimpanzees
at Gombe for the first two years.
So Jane was walking into a place where the
chimpanzees were very scared of humans.
They had been hunted. They were not comfortable
with her being in their presence.
So she did a very, kind of, at the time,
thought to be a crazy thing.
She just went to this place called Jane's Peak
and every day she sat in the same clothes
with the same equipment
and was very still and watched them across the valley.
She stayed very consistent very predictable until
the chimps lost their fear from far away.
And then she subsequently over many years
was able to get them
to lose their fear from very close up.
Jane much like her mentor Louis,
there were two things about her.
She was very bold and brave
and wanted to do things her own way.
She also didn't have any formal college education.
She had only gone to secretary school.
So she decided "The best way to get to understand these animals is to study them as individuals.
I'd like to learn who they are.
I'd like to know their personalities.
I'd like to learn about who their friends are,
their emotions."
And she did crazy things like giving them names
instead of using numbers to identify them.
And the scientific establishment of the time
was like, "That's really cute, sweetie, but like,
that's not the way we do things."
And now here we are 60 years later and the Gombe study is still going strong,
as I'm evidence of standing in front of you.
So what Jane really changed in
the field of studying animal behavior
was making it okay eventually to think
about these animals in terms of being
individuals with individual personal
relationships, friendships, personalities
emotions. And really conducting close observation
of individuals and their individual stories.
That's what was really different about
Jane's study with the chimps.
Now Jane was one of these 'Trimates,'
as I mentioned before.
And what's really interesting about these 3 is
they really did operate kind of like siblings.
So this is a story you have to dig to find out.
But Jane was very much the older sibling,
like the responsible one.
Dian [Fossey] has been reported
to be the kind of the jealous middle sibling.
And Birute [Galdikas] was like the happy baby
who's happy to be there with everybody.
And so Louis set up this system,
where after Jane's study became
a success, and he met Dian...
and Dian very similar to Jane walked up to him
and said, "I want to do what she did
but with a different animal."
He had this proving ground for Diane and then Birute.
And what he did was he would first send them
to Van Goodall in London.
They would have to stay with Van for several weeks
until she determined that they were okay.
And then he would send them to Jane in Gombe,
so she could field test them
and make sure they were okay.
Jane has never revealed what these metrics were,
so we don't know.
But at any rate Dian passed the test
and ended up, as I'll cover later, at Karisokie.
What's interesting about Dian is,
like Jane, she always had more of an
affinity for animals growing up than the normal girl.
She actually got along with animals quite
much more than she did with people.
She had a difficult childhood,
and she was desperate to be a veterinarian.
But she was really bad at chemistry and physics.
So instead she became
an occupational therapist with children.
She was actually fully fledged in her career
when she saw Louis Leakey give a talk
and walked up to him afterwards
and said, "That's what I want to do."
And so in 1967—Jane started Gombe in 1960;
Dian went out in 1967 to Rwanda
and started the Karisoke Research Center
and the long-term study of mountain gorillas there.
She did take a page out of Jane's book
and really think about studying these
animals as individuals, with individual
stories and histories and aspects to them.
She habituated the animals to her
presence much like Jane did.
And she did end up forging a very close
relationship with a particular animal,
a particular gorilla named Digit. And that's Digit
there looking at her field notes with her.
Digit, you know, they really, really
accepted Diane into their
into their community there, the gorillas.
And so she forges a very strong bond with Digit.
She has written about this that he was
her true best friend.
And he really greased the wheels with the other gorillas.
He accepted her and the other gorillas
were like, "Oh, okay, she must be alright."
So Digit really paved her way here. And this was
a friendship that would last all of Digit's life.
This picture was taken ten years later. Digit's a fully grown adult gorilla
who would seem to be quite terrifying to sit next to.
But they were very close friends until his death.
Now, his death is what changed Dian's life forever.
Dian one morning in 1977 got a report
that poachers were in her area in Rwanda.
She went out to check her groups
and she found Digit
with his head and his hands removed.
So she did a full 180 at that point from behavioral
research and went 100% into anti-poaching
and protection of the gorillas in her area.
And her methods for doing this were quite unorthodox.
They were outside of what we would envision as any
standardized conservation practices
that we would do today.
She basically chased after the poachers
with a knife and chased them off.
And so her anti-poaching efforts brought a lot
of anger to the poaching community.
And in 1985 she was killed in her research camp
in a crime that has never been solved.
So she is buried next to her best friend Digit.
You can actually visit her grave site in Rwanda.
So Dian's personal story is over,
but there is a legacy of both these women
that I want to touch on
before I launch into what I specifically work on.
Jane is very much with us.
She's very much alive and well.
She has more energy than all of us in this room.
Her legacy is very strong. This picture in
the middle is
taken of a group of either current
or former researchers at Gombe
taken about two years ago.
Jane's here in the middle, I'm over here.
So this was taken about two years ago,
and around us you see where...
a lot of focus in the last couple decades
is bringing into the formal research
training our Tanzanian counterparts
in Tanzania. And there's several
of our Tanzanian PhDs
and doctors of veterinary medicine there.
The Dian Fossey legacy...
despite her passing many years ago now,
is also quite strong.
An incredible presence in Rwanda working
very cooperatively with the government
in terms of both behavioral research
and anti-poaching.
And Dian's legacy of, especially
involving women in field research,
is clear there as you look at
the pictures around the edges.